[Music]
hi
i'm isaac in this video i'm going to
give you an overview of apogee's api
monitoring capabilities
apis are the foundation of modern
connected applications
from mobile banking to self-driving cars
from retail to healthcare
nearly every digital interaction today
is underpinned by apis
therefore api service degradations can
directly impact your customers
experience
your reputation and even your revenue
to ensure seamless connected experiences
for developers customers and partners
operations teams today want to assure
api service quality
proactively identify api issues before
customers do
quickly diagnose those issues and take
appropriate remedial actions
fast all of these capabilities are
available through the apigee edge
platform to empower your operations
teams
and increase api reliability let me show
you
apigee api monitoring can alert you to
live issues via slack
pagerduty or in this case email
clicking through you can see the alert
details including a link to a playbook
that recommends remedial action for this
particular type of issue your playbook
could be a wiki
page a diagnostics manual a triage
flowchart
or other relevant documentation of your
choice let's go a little deeper here
clicking through you are now taken to a
rich contextual view of the error and
the circumstances surrounding it
in the first section you can find the
basic condition details
and again a link to the playbook
scrolling down
you can see these powerful co-occurrence
matrices two-dimensional views that
allow you to quickly visualize and
pinpoint the nature and source of the
error
operations teams can often spend hours
navigating multiple systems to gather
and cross-correlate this information
but apogee api monitoring can provide it
for you in just a few clicks
you can also click the report icon on
the right to generate a custom report
you'll see it's already pre-populated
with just the right set of filters
specific to this error condition
to help others investigate a similar
issue faster from here
click on the menu button on the right to
navigate to the timeline view this gives
the ability to view the performance of
components of your api system over time
for this particular proxy we're looking
at the past three months of activity
creating an alert trigger in apigee edge
is straightforward in a monitoring
dashboard
click on alerts and then the button to
add an alert you can specify the
condition
you can set thresholds without
dimensions and under dimensions
you can also select a collection of
interest a collection to grouping of
proxies and targets that you want to
monitor closely as a unit
apigee api monitoring lets you see a
snapshot of historical condition data
overlaid with your thresholds to set
just the right values
this is just a quick sample to get these
monitoring capabilities for your traffic
all you need to do is to create an
apigee edge a proxy for your apis
and direct client applications to use it
and of course
all of the data presented here is
available via our own apis
so you can connect it to your analysis
audit and service management tools
okay that's a quick introduction to
apigee edge api monitoring
it provides contextual insights into api
performance
helps quickly diagnose issues and
facilitates remedial actions
for service assurance and business
continuity if you want to know more
dive into the product documentation or
visit the community
that's it from me until next time keep
those apis running